the FDA approving a coronavirus test
that could give results in about 15
minutes the pharmaceutical company
behind it now ramping up production
saying it expects to deliver 50,000
tests starting next week let's go to
Steve Harrigan now he's live in Atlanta
outside CDC headquarters ignore it Steve
arthel that news really shows just how
dramatically and quickly things are
changing when it comes to testing a
couple of weeks ago it was days wait for
a lab result to come back just last week
we were talking about the FDA approving
for the first time a test which could
come back in 45 minutes a so-called
point-of-care test that would let you
know within that amount of time whether
or not you have the virus
now abbott labs saying they are ready
with a test that can come in in under 15
minutes a positive result in as little
as five minutes this really could be a
game-changer the lab says it's going to
roll out fifty thousand test units a day
FDA approved beginning on Monday also
the World Health Organization saying
it's beginning historic drug trial
treatments volunteers from Norway and
Spain beginning those treatments to see
what works the best against the corona
virus four of the most promising drugs
will be tested in these trials malaria
medications antiviral compounds as well
as HIV compounds all being tested to see
which is the most effective against the
corona virus arthel back to you Steve
Harrigan thank you very much